Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a fully in-house Disney paper on how
to teach a neural network to capture the appearance
of clouds.
This topic is one of my absolute favorites
because it is in the intersection of the two
topics I love most - computer graphics and
machine learning.
Hell yeah!
Generally, we use light simulation programs
to render these clouds, and the difficult
part of this is that we have to perform something
that is called volumetric path tracing.
This is a technique where we have to simulate
rays of light that do not necessarily bounce
off of the surface of objects, but may penetrate
their surfaces and undergo many scattering
events.
Understandably, in the case of clouds, capturing
volumetric scattering properly is a key element
in modeling their physical appearance.
However, we have to simulate millions and
millions of light paths with potentially hundreds
of scattering events, which is a computationally
demanding task even in the age of rapidly
improving hardware.
As you can see here, the more we bump up the
number of possible simulated scattering events,
the closer we get to reality, but the longer
it takes to render an image.
In the case of bright clouds here, rendering
an image like this can take up to 30 hours.
In this work, a nice hybrid approach is proposed
where a neural network learns the concept
of in-scattered radiance and predicts it rapidly
so this part we don't have to compute ourselves.
It is a hybrid because some parts of the renderer
are still using the traditional algorithms.
The dataset used for training the neural network
contains 75 different clouds, some of which
are procedurally generated by a computer,
and some are drawn by artists to expose the
learning algorithm to a large variety of cases.
As a result, these images can be rendered
in a matter of seconds to minutes.
Normally, this would take many-many hours
on a powerful computer.
Here's another result with traditional path
tracing.
And now the same with deep scattering.
Yep, that's how long it takes.
The scattering parameters can also be interactively
edited without us having to wait for hours
to see if the new settings are better than
the previous ones.
Dialing in the perfect results typically takes
an extremely lengthy trial and error phase
which now can be done almost instantaneously.
The technique also supports a variety of different
scattering models.
As with all results, they have to be compared
to the ground truth renderings, and as you
can see here, they seem mostly indistinguishable
from reality.
It is also temporally stable, so animation
rendering can take place flicker-free as is
demonstrated here in the video.
I think this work is also a great testament
to show how these incredible learning algorithms
can accelerate progress in practically all
fields of science.
And given that this work was done by Disney,
I am pretty sure we can expect tons of photorealistic
clouds in their upcoming movies in the near
future.
There are tons of more details discussed in
the paper, which is remarkably well produced,
make sure to have a look, the link is in the
video description.
This is a proper, proper paper, you don't
want to miss out on this one.
And, if you enjoyed this episode and you feel
that the series provides you value in the
form of enjoyment or learning, please consider
supporting us on Patreon.
You can pick up cool perks there like deciding
the order of the next few episodes, and you
also help us make better videos in the future.
Details are available in the description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!